[Really sick dubstep/Yodel/Carnival fusion music]
*Just another day in the life of Markiplier* *Yodeling*
*Accurate simulation of being on drugs*
*Hey what's up guys*
*Here we go again*
*Cut to Mark taking picture with fan*
*unicorn*
*rainbow lightsticks*
*Exclusive Star Wars VIII Trailer*
[Soft sims-like music]
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier. And welcome to the funkalicious beats of Lichtspeer.
Now this game is interesting, because from the preview
I thought at first it was a side-scrolling platformer, and that may still be...
But!
[GAME]: "Choose your lichtmeister"
Heeeeelllll yeah...
Hans? Hemlut, Hildebrand, Ivo, Johann
Karl, Luther, Norbert, Otto, Rudolf, Seigfried...
Ulrich, Wilhelm, Wolfgang, Albert, Andreas, Bruno
Dieter, Dietrich, Frits, Gunther
Ohhhh, Gunther. Ohh I love a good Gunther!
Oh god "Das is Ok" (laughs)
Is this game... Rage quit mode?
If you are just beginning your lightspearing adventures in space, we recommend you avoid rage-quit mode honestly
WELL!
OH LOOKIE HERE! IT'S ANOTHER GAME TRYING TO TELL GUNTHER HOW TO LIVE HIS LIFE!
WELL GUNTHER DON'T LIKE THAT VERY MUCH
GUNTHER 'GOIN STRAIGHT IN'TA RAGE QUIT MODE.
Oh 'we're thinking'
Yeah I be thinking you're dumb.
"Achtung!"
*reading on screen text*
*getting cut off as 'sense'*
-aaaahh, shitty tits.
I read fast and I still couldn't blast through it
But Gunther don't need 'ta read! Ahh, Gunther.
The Ancient German from the Future™, y'know..
Oh hi Aku!
D'anybody else think that was Aku from Samurai Jack?
[Game grumbling]
...Okay?
Alright!
uhhhhuh~
Ah sacred mission, I like- Gunther like!
A great honor!
*kitten like sniffle*
Oh, cool!
The fantastisch, intergalactic, uber powerful...
Is it the Lichts- oooOHH FUCK DUDE.
....HEeeehehehheeell to the yeEEEAAAH.
Ohhh FUCK yeaaah!
Ohh mY GAAAAD- GUNTHER HAS D'POWER
OH GOD.
Fuck yeah, dude!
HELL YEAH.
Well I mean I think I'll be dead...
Ah, y'know that whole 'dying' thing..
I don't like the sound of-
*mark chuckles manically*
I don't like the sound of the whole 'dying' thing that you've got in store for me.
daz- dahs ancient vildvood
vYldvood- I don't speak german.
I can't even do a German accent...But that's not gonna stop me from trying!
When is being bad at something, stopped Markiplier from being offensive?
HERE WE GO!!!
Meet the nice wizards, get at least 200 headshots, do not use Lichtpowers...
Licht, le-- Oh...
Oh my-- Oh my god...
Hold the left mouse button to aim....
Oh shit...
Well...
Not doing good so far...
Oh that is so rad!
I can already tell I'm gonna be bad at this!
Now you will learn how to use the Trispear!
After shooting a spear, press 'A' to split.
Ohhh, I see how we do...
He-eh!
(Triumphant Laugh)
Well done! Now you're ready to die! A LOT- Ahhh shit...
Alright, ok...
Who says I'm gonna die?
Hoho, they're dead- Oh jeez!
Ah god-- AHH!!!!
Ok, we're doing good!
Oh my god, there's a lot of them-- Oh boy, I'm doing good I can't even talk!
Oh boy Oh boy Oh boy Oh boy Oh boy Oh boy Oh boy Oh boy....
Getting- getting ahead...
Oh-can- TAKE THAT YOU-
I'm assuming Santa's elves from the bottom there and then ice giants...
OH HELLO!
I did it though! My GOD! That was impossible!
BUT IT WAS AWESOME!
THIS GAME IS RAD!
OH MY GAWWWD
K, I gotta loo- gotta remember exactly how long until it's charged up
Oh my God does that guy have a shield?
How does that count as a miss?
Do I gotta uh-
Oh I gotta get him right on the tip top of his head
OH MY GOD! Stay back!
Stay back! x2
Stay back! x3
Stay back! x4
OH GOD!
Stay back! x5
Stay back! x6
Staaay back! x7
Stay back! x8
Stay back! x9
Stay back! x10
Oh boy!
Oh boy they're gonna be hard to hit
Hah!
Ho boy!
AAAAH!
Oh no! D:
Oh God! That's all it takes?!
Man no wonder I'm gonna die a lot
I'm not ready for this shit!
I don't need this kind of responsibility in my life
UGH! Gunther's gonna get it
Ah! Gunther's gonna get it a million ways!
It's a weird rhythm to get into
Because it shoots on letting go of the mouse
Which is not intuitive to a lot of like-- shooters that I've done before
so like
Oh my God! Why do those guys have like tiny knives?
They look like lawn gnomes
And the zombies?
I have no idea what's going on.
And--Did it start me on the beginning again just cuz I died?
Oh my God. This is gonna be so horrible.
OH BOY
I can't believe I'm going for this again, I'm not gonna do so well.
But so many of 'em
OH BOY [3x] I don't care if I missed
I just care that don't die horribly
I wish I could see like my mouse or something so that I can know where I'm targeting
like in the distance but its just like the
the curve triangle trajector. It's so difficult.
WHY IT IS SO DIFFICULT?!
AHHH! WHY IS GUNTHER HAVING SUCH A BAD TIME!
OHHHHH NO NO NO! STAY AWAY
HEY
NEIN?!
WHAT DID I DO?!
WHAT DID I DO? Did I miss?
Is that what it is? You--
I "quote unquote" missed
Alright
UGH
FUCKING FUCK
HOLY SHIT BALLS
There's so many dead bodies!
Gunther! What have you done?!
How've you been summoned from the future past?
My god.
I hope this is amusing
Its--Its--Its- It does seem quite intellegent for everybody. You know here
To just be like running towards the guy with a horrible spear
Why does this Light God even need to fight these battles here
GODDAMMIT STOP IT
LET ME MISS! I'M TERRIBLE!
Don't you know this? Don't you know you picked the wrong champion?
Gunter ain't cut out for this
GUNTHER WAS A POTTER!
NOT HARRY POTTER!
Well, I mean I am hairy.
AH! It's a bad joke! (Yes.)
Okay! EH! Got me of a bit
Okay! We're doing okay
We're doing alright [2x]
STOP!
STAPH!
Stop being such a a-hole. Okay
Imma get you right in your--OH! YOU POPPED UP AT THE WRONG TIME BITCH!
Hunter Gunther gotcha with his lichtspeer
Alright, who's ready to get fucked?
YOU!
Who is you?!
OH JEEZ
I'M NOT READY FOR THAT!
Are those doggos?
I don't wanna hit dogg--OH GOD [2x]
I kinda wanna hit doggos when they're about to bite my face off
Oh geez [3x]
*screams*
NOO! *santa claus like laugh*
NOOOO!
AH!
Fuck it. TO THE MAP!
Oh boy
Good god that's hard.
OH! I was on number one!
OHH! Can I buy stu--
I have no LSD?!
I have to get LSD to be able to do this?
I have none! *laughs* Cuz I wasn't able to complete a single damn level?
Well I am just not good enough. Ah--I get it
I have comment down not for rage quit mode.
Alright! Fuck Gunther the first
Let's get uh
Alright
Hel---I was hoping it's gonna be Helga
I don't even need to look at the other ones
Helga is okay.
Come at me, bros!
I'm ready to die. Yes [4x]
Oh--Is this--Is this really the difference that we're getting from
This--this--this is really the difference?
This is incredible!
Man! Why did I try rage quit mode?? This is sooo much better!! Nailed ya!
Oh got ya in the gullet
Oh this is much
This is so much better
I bet I got a lot of LSD if I done it the other way
The problem is my screen is very big
So it's like
hard to visualize the entire arc of the screen
smaller might actually work a lot better
Hell yeah. That was it!?
I had Frost Giants pouring up my ass
in the very beginning round, and now I got nobody!
I'm fricking loney out here with my lichtspeer
I mean--I could wait for them to get closer but this is more fun
OH! It counted that one!
I must be awesome
Ohh, right in your sunglasses man!
Sorry to ruin your shades buddy, but uhh-
that's the way it rolls.
Imma wait for them to get closer because I bet I could build up a pretty honking multiplier
Cuz I'm Markiplier. Oh hello!
;-;
So much more relaxed. I feel better
I feel good
I feel free
Fun
Happy and Fresh
Alright c'mon! Give me something hard!
Don't give me something hard please.
Oh god. Not the doggos
OH! Got that
Doggo with a headshot oh my god.
Why do these guys have shades?
I mean--I know it's the future
But I didn't think I'd be murdering
Fashionable Frost Giants
Not something that I thought I would've encountered in this
In my existence practic--Oh no! I finally missed
Oh no. I got someone in the end there--oh okay.
Shibibam
Ohh. I feel so bad..
Habiraghp
*strange accent* Right in your toe
Rrright in your toe
I know that's not German
But again
Offensive fucker right here
Ohh. This looks final
Is this gonna be the last one?
You gonna actually give me something
Threatening? Something dangerous??
something maybe a little bit...problematic for me?
Oh! Who's that up there?
Hey!
Who do you think you are?
Who do you--oh hello.
Who do you think you --*laughs*
Oh. You're no one anymore
Unfortunately for you, not for me. Hey. Hi. Okay. Go away now.
*laughs* dead
Anybody? Anybody else we got two sorcerers up there
And I'm running fancy and free off to--
YEAH! *laughs*
I had frickin' n--I had--I got an A!
In accuracy!
If I was still in the school I didn't finish. I'd be great
UUUBER!
*laugh* Hell yeah!
Hell yeah!
Oh hell-- this game is awesome
This an awesome game. Oh man. Everybody got to play this game
OH, I've got a great idea
OH, I'VE got a great IDEA
OHHH, I'VE GOT A GREAT IDEA
But anyway, yeah, you guys should totally play this game
See you in a bit...
Buh-bye!
*laughs before going away*
*war drums*
*epic music for lightsaber battle*
*deep voice* I REQUIRE MORE ENTERTAINMENT. THOSE AMONG YOU, BATTLE TO THE DEATH.
THE WINNER SHALL GAIN MY FAVOR.
THE LOSER SHALL BE DAMNED TO DIE AGAIN AND AGAIN.
BEGIN!!
*BATTLE START!*
*EPIC BATTLE MUSIC* *LASER NOISES*
*BATTLE END!*
*Mark making fart noises each hit*
Oh-- Is that?
More challengers I see??
Come at me then!
OOP, you're dead. Oop, you're dead.
oh-- OOH, you're also dead.
OH WHAT'S THAT? You're dead. Oh sorry! DEAD.  Oh Okay, don't- didn't even try. You're dead.
OH! Another one! Sorry, the bodies are piling up. You're dead.
You're--you're dead. You're dead. You're dead. You--you're dead--
You--you're dead, you're dead... OH, CAREFUL, NO! OH GOD
*crowd giggling* You're dead, and the final boss-- heh, hah, fight, fight, fight! Uh-oh
Hang on. Wait-- and oh you're dead. OKAY!
"right in the nuts.." Sorry, you okay? "I'm good" I'm so sorry!
Ah. Alas. Sweet prince, gone from this world. Died like the little bitch he was.
And now I shall ride into the sunset for glory, and a better light spear. LICHTSPEER!!
*Triumphant, intense music*